des musées fermés c'est l'une des
conséquences de la pandémie de covile 19
rassurez-vous des visites virtuelles
sont proposés sur internet à l'image de
celle du louvre admirer des oeuvres sans
bouger de chez soi
un concept qui peut paraître normal
aujourd'hui pourtant au milieu des
années 90 il n'en est qu'à ses débuts en
france bien au chaud chez vous vous
allez désormais pouvoir visiter le
louvre en pantoufles et cela grâce à
votre ordinateur
le premier musée au monde à avoir
proposé une exposition virtuelle c'est
celui du louvre en janvier 1995 à
l'époque pas encore de site internet
pour le musée mais un cd rom au total
cent peintures ont été modélisés sur
ordinateur après huit mois de travail
les cds doivent permettre de mieux
comprendre mieux faire comprendre des
oeuvres d'art et de donner des
possibilités qui ne que seul après le
louvre c'est au tour du musée d'orsay de
lancer un cd rom en 1996 exposer les
oeuvres via un ordinateur
c'est aussi une manière d'attirer un
nouveau public plus jeune
maintenant c'est devenu véritablement un
achat familial on se rend compte que les
familles s'équipent en ordinateur
multimédia pour l'éducation des enfants
et que dans l'éducation des enfants
intervient bien sûr l'éducation
culturelle
après les visites virtuelles sur cd-rom
arrive scène sur internet à la fin des
années 90 plusieurs avantages à cela des
oeuvres numérisées à des fins de
conservation mais aussi des
fonctionnalités plus étendues
alors l'avantagé sur d'internet c'est de
pouvoir créer des liens interactifs et
faire en sorte qu'on puisse voir avoir
un maximum d'informations sur ces
oeuvres d'un simple clic
en 2015 le muséum d'histoire naturelle
d'autun va même plus loin dans
l'attractivité grâce à un robot
téléguidé
vous pouvez désormais assister à une
exposition depuis chez vous un
dispositif destiné notamment aux
personnes hospitalisées et aux
établissements scolaires
deux fenêtres en fait de visualisation
qui nous permet de devoir déjà le socle
du robot son environnement immédiat
savoir où l'on va et puis une ville
telle une visualisation plus large qui
nous permet de nous diriger dans un
espace que l'on connaît avec la crise du
colis de 19
de nombreux musées restent fermés à
l'image du château de versailles grâce à
la réalité virtuelle
le site propose une visite interactive
sur internet pour admirer la galerie des
glaces ou la cour royale de conditions
téléchargez une application sur le web
et disposer d'un casque de réalité
virtuelle
[Musique]